An anti Islam politician who wants to ban mosques
wins the Dutch election.
A far right populist
was previously called for a ban on the Quran,
Islamic schools and mosques
as immersed.
The shock winner in the Dutch election,
Gertz Builders,
is set to win 37 seats ahead of his nearest rival,
putting him in the top position to
form a ruling coalition
and potentially
become the country's next prime minister. However,
he will now have to convince other parties to join
him in a coalition
with the target of seventy
six seats in the hundred and fifty seat parliament.
His election campaign,
builders has called for a total hulk to
accepting asylum seekers
and a referendum on the Netherlands leaving
the European Union,
dubbed an exit.
Builders turned down
his anti Islam rhetoric in the run up to the vote,
saying he was prepared to put in the fridge
his policies on banning the Quran,
mosques and Islamic schools.
The Netherlands will be returned to the Dutch,
the asylum tsunami and migration will be curbed,
he said in a statement.
After the polls emerged in 2,009.
The British government refused
to let him visit the country,
saying he posed a threat to community harmony
and therefore
public security.
Well, that's a very sad day for the United Kingdom.